salut vous allez voir un spectacle de
parce qu'on en pense
vous allez voir un spectacle de
mentalisme inédit que j'ai écrit en 24
heures que j'ai joué qu'une seule fois
pour le mettre sur youtube ça s'appelle
One Shot 2 parce qu'il y a eu un si vous
avez pas vu le 1 d'ailleurs il est dispo
sur ma chaîne youtube avec un petit docu
vlog des 48 heures durant lequel je l'ai
créé oui parce que le 1 j'avais créé en
48 heures là j'ai créé en 24 heures
24 secondes
je me chauffe
aussi
si vous le souhaitez avant ou après le
spectacle regarder le document des 24
heures de la création on a tout
documenté la vidéo est dans la chaîne
secondaire dont le lien est dans la
description d'avancer je peux comme ça
évidemment c'est pas la même qualité la
même puissance que les spectacles que je
fais habituellement sur scène comme
celui que je vais faire appeler Yelle ou
en tournée prochainement parce que eux
c'est des spectacles qui demandent un an
de préparation et qui vont être joué
plusieurs centaines de fois
du coup faut que je la passe de quelque
part bref c'est un projet créatif 100%
gratuit qu'on met comme ça sur Youtube
j'espère que ça va vous plaire moines
Shot 2 c'est quand c'est maintenant ça
fait 24 secondes
[Musique]
merci d'être ici parce que tout seul
c'est vachement moins drôle surtout pour
faire du mentalisme seul alors là après
avoir créé un spectacle en 48 heures
j'ai créé un spectacle en 24 heures mais
en version intime et je sais pas
pourquoi ça me fait un peu moins peur
parce que je me dis que comme c'est en
version intime je peux discuter avec
vous tu vois là je suis pas sur scène en
train de faire ouais ça va le double
fond
tu vois
il y a une énergie plus bas c'est on est
un peu comme à la maison quoi tu vois et
c'est cool et du coup je me suis dit
dans cette ambiance là je peux aussi un
peu plus raconter des choses tu vois les
choses qui me fascinent les choses de
mon histoire aussi peut-être moi je suis
fasciné par exemple par le fait qu'il y
ait de l'infini partout connaissez le
concept de l'infini et dès qu'il y a de
l'infini bah en fait il y a toutes les
données du monde qui sont toujours dans
l'infini tu vois par exemple si on prend
un nombre irrationnel et transcendant
comme racine de 2 c'est-à-dire que
derrière la virgule ça va jusqu'à
l'infini ça se répète pas donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a toutes les données du
monde dans Racine de 2 vous êtes content
d'être venu
non mais c'est des points qui me
fascinent et qui a fasciné en plus toute
ma famille moi j'étais alimentée par mon
grand-père qui me parlait de tout ça
c'est un agriculteur mais il était très
très curieux tu vois de tout en plus il
avait un petit don
je vais vous raconter un peu il avait un
don il était capable si tu lui posais
une carte à jouer devant lui mon
grand-père il savait te dire quelle
carte c'était mais vraiment on joue à ça
le week-end on allait le voir et tout et
donc on prenait n'importe quel jeu de
cartes on mettait une carte on disait
c'est quelqu'un qui disait 4 de trèfle
tu retournes de 13h que même si nous on
savait pas quelqu'un de s'était il
arrivait à la deviner à chaque fois
c'est fou quand même et il avait une
passion pour ça il avait une deuxième
passion mon grand-père c'était l'alcool
ouais du coup il passait il passait
beaucoup de temps au bistrot à côté et
forcément une passion en suivant une
autre régulièrement il prenait le jeu de
cartes du bistrot les gars du village il
savait qu'il faisait ça donc il parier
un verre contre ça bah ça marche bien
parce que rentrer bourré à chaque fois
donc il partait sans argent et rentrer
il était alcoolisé et après ça ça c'est
un petit peu dégradé on va dire dans la
déontologie parce qu'il a commencé à
parier de l'argent mais je peux
peut-être gagner un petit peu de sous
avec ça donc il a commencé à faire des
paris pour gagner de l'argent là-dessus
il est Paris ont augmenté jusqu'au jour
où il y avait un gros flambeur qui était
là dans le village entend parler de mon
grand-père il me fait monter les Paris
il fait monter la sauce ça monte très
haut à tel point que mon grand-père il a
pas de quoi mettre sur la table donc il
pose les clés de la maison et Paris sa
maison ok mais c'est pas grave il a
toujours réussi toute sa vie à trouver
la carte qui prend pas un gros risque le
flambeur pose une carte comme ça face en
bas mon grand-père dit quelqu'un c'est
il retourne la carte c'est presque la
carte c'est la bonne couleur c'est la
bonne famille mais la valeur a un cran
pré à un point près s'est trompé et
c'est rien de se tromper d'une carte
mais en attendant c'est pas la carte
donc il a perdu la maison et du coup il
a arrêté de faire ça et selon lui selon
mon grand-père ce dont là il saute une
génération et quand il a vu que je
commençais à m'intéresser au mentalisme
et tout ça il s'est dit si elle se
trouve Fabien il a le don tu vois
et au début j'y croyais pas trop et puis
en grandissant je me dis mais c'est vrai
tu vois j'aime le mentalisme comme mon
grand-père j'aime l'alcool comme mon
grand-père du coup il y a des indices tu
vois je me dis ouais c'est possible
c'est possible en tout cas il m'a pris à
partir et il m'a dit il faut jamais que
tu paries de l'argent là-dessus il faut
que tu gardes ontologiques et du coup
pour que je garde ma déontologie il m'a
donné la carte qui lui a fait tout
perdre à l'époque ça c'est la carte de
l'époque qui lui a fait tout perdre et
il m'a dit tu la garde toujours sur toi
comme ça tu seras jamais tenté à chaque
fois tu penseras à moi qui ai tout perdu
avec ça sauf que ce qu'il appelle le don
en fait pour en avoir parlé avec lui
c'est un mélange d'intuition et de
hasard ni plus ni moins et je suis
persuadé que j'ai pas de don qui t'en
avais pas qu'en fait si on a accès aux
données de l'infini à toutes les données
qu'il y a dans l'infini alors c'est sûr
on est tous capables en fait de savoir
ce qui va se passer de savoir où sont
les choses d'écouter peut-être de
l'intuition et tout et je me dis que
ouais mon grand-père aurait trouvé moi
je suis sûrement capable de trouver mais
peut-être toi aussi tu es capable de
trouver ce qu'il y a derrière
c'est quoi ton prénom
Nice on va essayer de faire comme m'a
appris à faire mon grand-père donc un
mélange d'intuition et de hasard tu es à
l'aise avec les cartes à jouer c'est
quelque chose que tu maîtrises ok tu vas
imaginer 52 cartes à jouer dans ta tête
c'est beaucoup attends c'est beaucoup ça
prend beaucoup de place à visualiser
c'est un peu dur on va tal léger tu vas
prendre la moitié imagine il y a toutes
les rouges et toutes les noirs qui
flottent tu fais tomber les rouges ou
les noirs sur la table
je t'écoute
le rouge ok donc tu as toutes les Noirs
maintenant qui sont devant toi ok donc
tu te concentres et tu les vouvoies
vraiment elle continue de flotter il y a
les pics et les trèfles qui sont
mélangées et puisque c'est de
l'intuition tu vas faire s'approcher de
toi l'une des cartes qui en l'air tu
l'as fait s'approcher de toi tu vois si
c'est du Picout du Trèfle tu vois si
c'est une carte à point pour ceux qui
connaissent moins les cartes à point
c'est as 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ou si c'est
une figure c'est-à-dire les trois autres
valets d'amoura donc tu vois précisément
quelle carte c'est dans ta tête une
carte dans tête maintenant ne dis pas
laquelle mais tu en as une en tête oui
ça c'est l'intuition tu vois tu as fait
rapprocher une carte celle que tu
voulais intuitivement mélange
d'intuition et de hasard on va passer à
la phase du hasard juste pour voir tu
vas composer à partir de la carte
d'intuition une carte complètement au
hasard le hasard a des règles donc on va
se dire une cartoonner voici la manière
de la construire si ta carte c'était du
pic ben maintenant pense à une carte à
trèfle tu vois c'était du Trèfle à
l'inverse tu penses maintenant une carte
à pic tu as compris le principe
t'inverses tout très clair ok tu as une
nouvelle carte en tête maintenant la
carte du hasard c'est laquelle
le Val est trèfle et c'est ça qui est
intéressant en fait parce que tu es
parti de ton intuition on ne savait même
pas ce que c'était tu as suivi les
règles du hasard et tu termines sur le
valet de trèfle un mélange comme disait
mon grand-père d'intuition et de hasard
c'est fou
parce que c'est exactement la carte qui
a prononcé mon grand-père aussi à
l'époque et qu'il l'a fait perdre donc
tu t'es connecté à tout mais même plus
qu'à la carte à l'histoire même de mon
grand-père tu as dit Valley très comme
lui a dit à l'époque donc effectivement
tu es comme mon grand-père un cran en
dessous de la carte en fait c'est ça
qu'il faut après je pourrais la
retourner mais ça va vous énerver de
voir que tu as il a fait comme mon
grand-père d'aller trêve donc il a perdu
contre la carte qui en dessous a priori
la dame de trèfle
mais si je retourne l'impact émotionnel
il va être
mon grand-père vraiment a perdu contre
la dame de trèfle
voilà
et tu as réussi comme hier à l'époque
comme quoi on est quand même tous
capables de faire ça tu vois alors après
j'ai réfléchi quand même à tout ça aux
données de l'univers etc je la garde
c'est un souvenir et je me suis dit
ouais mais dans le fond on a une chance
sur 52 d'arriver à ça alors je me suis
dit qu'avec vous on est on est on est 30
c'est quand même énormément de personnes
on pouvait aller plus loin non c'est pas
énorme 30 tu sais que ça paraît pas
énorme hein 30 c'est fou le rapport
qu'on a au nombre aux choses etc tu vois
en fait un nombre seul il veut rien dire
mais c'est rare que tu sois avec 30
personnes dans ta vie et c'est rare qui
est 30 personnes qui t'écoutent tu vois
et en plus aujourd'hui la météo on fait
des vidéos sur internet tu vois quand
quelqu'un fait 5000 vues on se dit ah
c'est nul quoi il s'est planté 5000
personnes c'est énorme si on les mettait
dans cette pièce dans meurs
c'est un Zénith internal tu vois on a du
mal à avoir la proportion des choses tu
vois moi je m'amuse beaucoup avec ça à
voir la proportionnalité des choses tu
vois par exemple la différence qu'il y a
entre le Soleil et la Terre c'est pas
très clair pour moi j'arrivais pas à le
comprendre la différence de taille et
ben si tu transformais la terre en grain
de sable le soleil il serait aussi gros
qu'une balle de tennis tu vois et là tu
fais ouais il est gros le soleil
j'ai besoin de ça pour comprendre bref
là je disais on avait une chance sur 52
je me dis qu'on peut aller plus loin en
prenant les lettres et les mots tu vois
essayer de refaire ce genre de lecture
de l'infini parce qu'il y a de la
synchronicité un petit peu dans l'air
vous savez ce que c'est une sacondicité
c'est un hasard remarquable c'est par
exemple tu chantes une musique chez toi
tu allumes la radio et la radio elle
diffuse que tu chantais là tu fais waouh
faut que j'en parle à Michel le
téléphone sonne c'est Michel oh tu
connais ce genre de truc là l'infini la
synchronicité pour moi c'est un peu
relié et je me dis oui on peut le faire
avec des lettres les lettres sa forme
des mots les mots ça paraît presque
infini alors j'ai pris une compilation
de mots on appelle ça un livre
et je me suis dit on peut voir peut-être
moi j'en suis là j'en suis presque à la
fin c'est le prêtre l'assassin
il n'y a pas de prêtres dans le livre je
veux dire déjà on peut voir si peut-être
on est gravé un truc ensemble tu vois
dans le temps dans l'infini tu sais lire
non mais je le savais je suis mon
téléphone c'est quoi ton prénom Amber
comme ça ou en beurre ok vraiment arrête
de me parler fais ton truc
je comprends en verre tu peux me dire
STOP où tu veux tu liras le premier mot
de la page donc je vais essayer par le
bas comme ça on est sur je le verrai pas
stop ici tu lis le tout premier mot de
la toute première page tu l'as en tête
ouais c'est bon tu l'as retenu je le
fais voir pour la si la caméra veut
capter ça va Loïc
[Rires]
j'imagine que tu l'as filmé du coup
je vais essayer de retrouver ce mot je
vais prendre un calepin parce que il y a
deux théories il y a celle qui dit que
je suis capable de capter ce que tu
penses puis à celle qui dirait aussi que
peut-être depuis le début de l'univers
on savait que à ce moment précis de
l'univers tu penseras ce mot est-ce que
ça représente quelque chose qui existe
dans le monde physique quelque chose que
je peux toucher oui d'accord ok tu peux
l'imaginer ok d'accord c'est très droit
oui ça c'est vu parce que tes yeux n'ont
pas fait ça ils ont fait ça comme ça ok
est-ce que il y a des sensations qui
peuvent être liées à ça oui ok
un peu comme ça
ça commence par une consonne c'est une
affirmation t'inquiète pas la deuxième
lettre pour moi c'est une voyelle
il y a dedans
oui
je pense que c'est parce que j'ai écrit
je suis en train de changer un petit peu
d'avis
est-ce que tu peux me dire exactement
quel mot tu es en tête
fière ok alors je vous cache pas que
j'ai marqué bougie mais je l'ai changé
par cierge après c'est pas mal hein
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou ça mais là c'est moi qui le
fait ça vous bluff pas mais non mais
vous vous dites attends mais olicard
c'est normal il arrive à faire des trucs
comme ça il fait ça depuis des années et
tout moi je pense que si ma théorie est
bonne et qu'on a accès à toutes les
données vous êtes capable de le faire
sur moi
parce que j'ai croisé ton regard et tu
as fait non
je vais le faire je viens de te donner
un micro comme ça tu auras pas à bouger
le micro il doit être juste ici c'est
quoi ton prénom
je m'appelle Apolline Apolline Apolline
enchantée je vais choisir un mot moi
dans le livre
et tu vas le deviner je vais essayer
ouais c'est un peu osé hein je vais
t'aider si tu veux tu peux fermer les
yeux ou pas dans ce que je vais te
proposer l'idée c'est d'imaginer devant
un tableau d'école peut-être dans une
classe pas trop jeune quand même tu vois
tu as 12 ans à 12 ans tu as déjà le
cerveau qui commence à raisonner comme
un adulte il te montre que un peu
d'expérience un peu de données mais moi
je me souviens qu'à 12 ans en fait
j'aimais pas qu'on me prenne pour un
petit tu vois donc tu as 12 ans tu es
devant ce grand tableau tu vois et
imagine alors attends je vais d'abord
choisir un mot au moins sinon ça va pas
fonctionner ok je vais prendre ça
et imagine un soit un mot que tu
écrirais ou que tu dessinerais c'est à
dire c'est j'ai pas pris évidemment
quelque chose d'extrêmement compliqué tu
peux imaginer un objet tu peux imaginer
ce que tu veux j'ai pas j'ai pas pris un
verbe conjugué ou des choses comme ça tu
vois écrit sur ton tableau noir et tu ne
me dis ce que tu as écrit on verra si ça
correspond bien à ma pensée
et à suspense c'est pas de table
c'est bon alors tu penses que je pense à
quel mot moi je pensais à un arbre un
arbre c'est incroyable parce que
vraiment j'avais mon doigt sur un seul
mot vous pouvez confirmer ouais c'est
sur le mot arbre à Pauline
[Applaudissements]
sur une pomme sur une pomme et puis
après tu es remonté c'est fou parce que
ça n'a rien à voir avec arbre tu vois ce
que j'ai
pas le mot précis nous sous-estime pas
ta performance
a été extrêmement bluffante je
terminerai le livre et je te l'enverrai
comme ça tu pourras tu pourras lire tu
verras s'il y a arbre toutes les deux
lignes ou pas tu vois mais encore une
fois c'était assez fini quand même parce
que il y avait 60000 à 100000 mots
possible et encore je t'en ai enlevé je
t'ai dit c'est pas un verbe conjugué tu
vois pour moi c'était trop donc en vrai
on était limité à que quelques dizaines
de milliers de mots c'est pas très
bluffant ce que tu as fait
c'est bluffant mais c'est limité je
pense qu'on peut aller encore plus loin
que ça du moins c'est ce que je me suis
dit en théorie tu vois un truc un truc
quasiment infini toi en parlant de
l'infini
là j'ai combien de briques de l'écho
dans ma main j'en ai 6 exactement donc
tu te dis j'ai j'ai 6 dans la main tu
vois j'ai ce chiffre là j'ai cette
quantité là et en fait je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord parce qu'en fait il y a
8 points sur les Lego
donc 6 x 8 48 et là dans ma main je
tiens 48 ça pèse 48 c'est plus que vous
là j'ai plus dans ma main que dans cette
salle
moi je prends la même drogue que vous
et après je me suis dit j'ai peut-être
plus que 48 je me suis dit il y a
combien de possibilités d'emboîter ces 6
légaux de manière différente tu vois ça
c'est une des manières possibles dans
boiter les silos vous pensez qu'il y a
combien de manières on va faire un petit
sondage est-ce qu'il y a plus de 100
manières
ok levez les mains comme ça sera plus
visuel est-ce qu'il y a plus ah ouais
lever tous la main et vous les baissez
au fur et à mesure lever tous
qui pensent qu'il y a moins de 100
manières et vous baissez la main dans
ces cas-là moins de sommeil à moins de
1000 manières différentes de les
emboîter vous baissez la main
à moins de 100 000 manières
à moins de 500 000 manières
moins d'un million de manière
moins de 10 millions de manières
moins de 100 millions de manières
il me reste trois personnes vous pouvez
baisser les mains
très vite soit parce qu'elle le savent
ce parce qu'elles sont intuitives de ce
côté-là il y a 195 millions
996 manière d’emboîter ces silos ça veut
dire que dans ma main les gars j'ai 195
millions c'est fou quand je vous disais
que l'infini était caché partout tu vois
c'est moi je trouve ça dingue c'est
exponentielle en fait en réalité alors
je cherchais comment continuer cette
petite recherche là avec vous on n'est
pas loin de l'ésodérisme tu vois avec
avec quelque chose de moins limité je me
suis en fait le moins limitée c'est les
formes c'est les dessins c'est à dire
que si je vous demander un papier à tous
et que je vous demandais de dessiner une
voiture vous feriez tous une voiture
différente et même si je mettais un
modèle de voiture un dessin simple vous
demandant à tous de le reproduire ce
serait quand même des voitures
différentes je me suis dit donc les
dessins les dessins c'est sûr c'est une
manière un peu de frôler l'infini et
après je suis allé encore plus loin dans
la réflexion si tout ça est connecté par
une forme de synchronicité dans les
données du monde cachées dans l'infini
il faut suivre
ça veut dire que si je vous fais faire
des dessins en voyant vos dessins je
pourrais savoir qui a dessiné quoi c'est
sûr parce que vous allez imprégner ce
dessin de vous alors j'ai pris de quoi
dessiner j'ai pris trois petits stylos
qui vous seront laissés en souvenir
parce qu'on a un budget considérable
voilà les trois petits bouts de papier
je vais vous les confier qui qui veut
participer le veut la main on va le
faire comme ça une personne on va on va
prendre un petit peu partout dans la
salle quel est ton prénom Lauren tiens
alors tu vas tu vas dessiner cash bien
pour pas que je puisse le voir et
dis-toi que toutes les personnes
derrière toi sont mes complices et
qu'elles vont me dire ce que tu as
dessiné parce que comme ça tu seras sûr
de cacher tu seras sûr que je pourrai
pas y avoir accès je te jure que je vais
là-bas et attends que j'ai distribué à
tout le monde avant de commencer à
dessiner sinon je risque de voir lever
la main le porcine qui veulent ton
prénom c'est Lola je t'ai demandé ton
prénom oui je sais
j'étais presque une affirmation Lorraine
Lola tiens je te passe ça là OK et une
troisième personne un troisième stylo
qui veut participer oui quel est ton
prénom Sylvie tiens Sylvie je te donne
ça aussi vous dessinez ce que vous
voulez alors faudrait juste que ça
prenne pas trois heures donc me faites
pas la chapelle Sixtine non plus mais
vous allez dessiner ça je te regarde
pendant ce temps là c'est aussi une
manière de montrer aux autres que je
regarde pas ailleurs comme ça tant que
mon regard est dans le tien c'est que
c'est que je te vois que toi si je
décroche le regard tu cries à l'Esco et
arrête de me faire des Clerc
c'est quoi ton prénom la fin la fin tu
surveille bien mes yeux j'ai
l'impression que tu me l'hypnotises
est-ce que tu as terminé presque Lola et
c'est Sylvie la dernière personne tu as
terminé ok vous mettez bien le dessin
fasse en bas comme ça et je vais
demander potentiellement à une personne
à côté c'est qui qui est juste là Amber
Amber est-ce que tu peux récupérer vous
vous lui rendez les trois décembre vous
pouvez garder les stylos lui redonner
comme vous voulez et tu la récupères
bien face en bas il faut pas que je
puisse les voir vérifie bien même si tu
veux tu peux te mettre sur le côté tu
vérifies qu'on voit pas en transparence
dans ta main tu vois que c'est c'est bon
ok tu les mélanges un peu entre eux
est-ce qu'on t'a rendu des stylos
[Rires]
garder les stylos
je suis d'accord avec vous il y a pas de
petit bénéfice il y a pas de problème
donc on a dit il y avait l'au-delà
Sylvie et Lauren qui participaient tu
les as mélangés même toi tu connais pas
l'ordre là du coup tu as vraiment brassé
moi c'est cool c'est cool je vais mettre
comme ça pour pour mieux vous voir parce
que sinon la lumière m'éclate les yeux
j'ai besoin de voir vos visages tu me
vois toujours Loïc si je me mets comme
ça je me décalais ici ça passe à l'image
oui ça va là je regarde bien la caméra
là abonnez-vous
mais la main comme ça en beurre
c'est une maison c'est ça on est tous
d'accord mais c'est une maison
particulière c'est quand même une maison
qui a une petite porte qu'un cercle qui
a des nuages en ressort donc c'est
quelqu'un quand même qui est encore un
peu jeune dans sa tête
c'est intéressant comme maison tu vois
ça par exemple spontanément je sais que
c'est pas Lauren qui a fait ça parce
qu'en fait Lorraine je pense quand je te
vois que tu as un profil très créatif
mais en fait en réalité tu es vraiment
très rassuré quand les choses sont
cadrées tu te serais pas encombré de ce
petit truc là comme ça tu vois ou alors
si tu avais fait ça tu m'aurais fait
aussi les arbres et tout le décor je
pense donc ça c'est pas toi je regarde
un peu Sylvie je regarde un petit peu
Lola
tu vois ça précisément c'est pas toi je
l'affirme et j'affirme même maintenant
que c'est Lola est-ce que c'est bien toi
qui a fait la petite maison oui c'est ça
oui merci beaucoup Jonathan c'est bien
tu peux me donner le prochain juste le
prochain le prochain voilà merci
beaucoup OK
un chat souris
un mélange entre le chat et la souris je
sais pas trop ce que c'est je vous fais
voir ça alors là c'est là c'est pareil
en fait spontanément je prête
l'intention d'écrire un animal un peu
mignon et rigolo qui a une seule
personne ici et vraiment spontanément et
pour moi c'est Sylvie c'est sûr et
certain à
99,99%, c'est bien c'est bien à toi oui
merci beaucoup
Amber garde bien le dessin sécurisé dans
ta main parce que évidemment je sais
qu'il rentre
logique derrière
par contre je me dis que juste pour
clôturer sur le troisième dessin puisque
j'arrive à les réattribuer est-ce que on
pourrait même pas anticiper au final
dans tout ça ce que c'est tu vois
et je pense que si en fait en réalité je
suis quasiment persuadé que tu vas pas
dessiner quelque chose de vivant comme a
pu le faire Sylvie tu vois que tu vas
pas t'encombrer de ça je pense par
contre encore une fois que tu vas aller
dans quelque chose dans le détail mais
pas quelque chose de de mort
monumentalement parlant comme peut
l'être une maison une montagne ce genre
de choses je pense que tu as fait un
entre deux tu vois on avait le vivant et
on avait l'immobil je pense vraiment que
tu es entre les deux donc je te regarde
pas pour pas qu'on pense que je vois ton
visage mais
mais je pense que ouais tirer dans
quelque chose qui avance pas polluant
donc plutôt un vélo plutôt un vélo
est-ce que ça se rapproche d'un vélo oui
est-ce qu'on peut regarder précisément
c'est carrément un vélo non si c'est
carrément un vélo
c'est carrément vélo et puis moi j'avais
dit qu'elle elle fait plus de détails tu
vois elle fait pas des petits hibouis
bruit avec ce soit cadré un vélo c'est
comme ça il y a des rayons il y a
peut-être autant de rayons d'un côté
comme de l'autre je te laisse en
souvenirs
moi ça me fait un petit peu flipper tu
vois de me dire qu'en fait tout existe
dans tout que toutes les données du
monde existent partout le la première
fois que j'ai flippé un peu c'est
quand j'ai plié une feuille en deux dans
ma vie
ça ça m'a fait flipper
ça c'est mieux que l'infini encore c'est
mieux que les Lego ça là j'ai plié la
feuille en deux c'est comme si j'avais
deux feuilles d'épaisseur ça vous bluffe
on apprend des trucs sur ma chaîne là je
replie en deux
donc j'ai une épaisseur de quatre
feuilles ça va une vitesse Phalle là je
replie en deux donc j'ai l'épaisseur de
8 feuilles je repli encore en deux chez
l'épaisseur de 16 feuilles je remplis
encore en deux j'ai l'épaisseur de 32
feuilles tapé par
contre j'avais un dans la main et j'ai
32 maintenant j'ai pas plié beaucoup et
là si je replie
j'ai 64 mon pote qu'est-ce qu'elle a à
dire qu'est-ce que tu vas faire alors là
c'est très dur de replier encore en deux
mais si je replis en eux je reste 128
256 etc si j'arrivais à plier en deux
cette feuille 42 fois d'affilée j'aurais
en épaisseur la distance précise de la
Terre à la Lune
vous refusez mentalement cette
information mais je vous assure que en
42 fois c'est fou alors ce serait une
échelle très très fine par contre mais
une épaisseur comme ça juste en repliant
en repliant en repliant t'imagines la
distance qui attire un jour tu veux
voyager sur la lune
j'étais quand même offert le moyen le
plus écologique d'aller sur la lune
les gens disent pas merci c'est faux
alors moi je suis quelqu'un de très
rationnel je sais que j'ai pas de don
j'ai pas de pouvoir particulier et tout
et je me suis dit c'est à se trouve ce
qu'on appelle les voyants les médiums il
y a deux catégories il y a ceux qui
savent qu'ils n'ont aucun pouvoir comme
moi mais qui font semblant d'en avoir un
on peut les qualifier de charlatan et à
ceux qui pensent avoir un pouvoir à
savoir si c'est vrai ou pas mais qui
sont sincères dans leur démarche
et comme moi je n'y crois pas
personnellement je me dis que en fait il
pense avoir un pouvoir parce que ils ont
trouvé des moyens d'accéder comme ça aux
données de l'univers et à l'infini tu
vois
du coup j'avais envie de terminer en
faisant une petite expérience de voyance
avec vous une sorte de voyance on va
dire quelle qu'elle est ton prénom
Madame Corinne tu crois la voyance ouais
ok c'est l'échec
[Rires]
publicitaire ah oui aux appels
téléphoniques et aux voyants etc oui moi
comme je débute je vais faire de
l'astrologie juste tu vois c'est ce qui
me semble le plus accessible alors je me
suis inventé astrologue tu vois j'ai
donc pris pour être un bon astrologue
plusieurs choses
déjà j'ai construit mon jeu de cartes
alors je sais que c'est souvent des
cartes de tarot moi je préfère les
cartes normal les cartes à jouer mais
par contre comme je suis collectionneur
j'ai pris une carte de chacun de mes
paquets donc il y a pas il y a pas de
dos de cartes qui sont ta vie c'est
stylé il y a pas ça c'est altard tu sais
pour le plus vieux qui connaissent
League ça c'est les cartes de pub à la
coca voilà il y a des cartes de tous les
gens et ici je me suis fait un petit un
petit rappel parce que je suis pas un
très bon astrologue j'ai pas appris tous
les signes Parker donc j'ai tous les
signes et vous savez les signes
astrologiques vous croyez en mode signe
ou pas mais c'est toujours en tout cas
associé à un nombre fétiche à une
matière un élément à plein de choses
comme ça donc moi je les ai associés à
des chiffres c'est pas l'ordre
d'apparition de l'année c'est l'ordre
d'apparition de la première page Google
où j'ai demandé
et c'est une enveloppe dedans j'ai mis
ce que j'espère être une synchronicité
entre Corinne et moi si je suis un bon
astrologue alors que je sais que j'ai
aucun nom donc là je fais partie de la
deuxième catégorie non la première non
j'y crois pas et je sais que j'ai pas
d'eau ouais charlatan là je suis
Charlotte alors je vais maintenant j'ai
toutes mes cartes tu arrives au cabinet
la première chose que je fais en
arrivant en cabinet c'est du coup de te
demander 40 euros pas du tout c'est une
voyance gratuite
je mélange les cartes j'ai besoin
d'imprégner le jeu de mon âme
et de mon âme
d'ailleurs les voyants ils font pas
tellement ça ils font mélanger à la
personne pour ceux qui connaissent pour
qu'elles imprègnent un peu qui elles
sont là on je vais te donner une petite
moitié du jeu je pense aller encore un
petit peu de cas voilà comme ça TOI tu
vas mélanger tout ça hop tu regardes
parce que tu as comme carte juste pour
l'instant tu les mets ça marche moi je
vais continuer à mélanger de mon côté ça
c'était ma manière de mélanger avant
comme ça j'essaie sûr de pas en faire
tomber donc n'hésite pas à reproduire
mon mélange
quand c'est bien mélangé tu me dis c'est
bien mélangé
ça te va ok comme ça tu as imprégné un
petit peu les cartes de toi je te
remercie de faire la passeuse c'est
gentil j'aurais de nouveau besoin de toi
dans deux secondes
parce que du coup maintenant les voyants
aussi te demandent de d'avoir une action
dans les gardes en général c'est de
choisir par exemple trois cartes on
pense à ta question etc moi je vais te
demander d'avoir une action liée à ton
signe astrologique je le connais pas tu
penses à ton signe astrologique si t'as
pas envie de penser au tien tu penses à
celui de quelqu'un d'autre j'ai pas
besoin de savoir auquel tu penses mais
toi tu dois penser à un signe en
particulier dans ta tête et dans
quelques secondes tu vas récupérer le
jeu et tu vas passer sous le jeu autant
de cartes qui correspondent au numéro du
signe alors je te le confie
tu lui passes tu le fais moi pendant ce
temps là je te regarde que toi dans les
yeux Lorraine comme ça je sais qu'on
voit pas ça me dirait pas grand chose là
pour la suite ça a pas tellement
d'intérêt mais je veux même être sûr que
je connais pas ça tu as terminé Corinne
peut-être presque
c'est bon je récupère le paquet merci
beaucoup donc tu as fait ton action tu
as imprégné les cartes moi aussi tu as
fait ton action etc et ensuite au moment
de faire le tirage les voyants eux ils
font souvent des figures géométriques
par exemple ils croient tu vois tu as un
côté c'est le passé le présent le futur
etc moi comme c'est l'estime
astrologique il y en a 12 je vais déjà
prendre que 12 cartes une deux trois
quatre cinq six sept huit neuf 10 11 12
voilà tac et puis avec ces 12 cartes je
vais faire une pendule ce joli une
pendule il y a 12 trucs donc ça ça va
être le 1 le 2 on va faire comme ça 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
et 12
ça fait une pendule un peu non c'est pas
c'est pas si mal
alors après avant avant de te tirer les
cartes je te demanderai par exemple de
penser à ton signe tu vois
c'est un signe c'est un signe volontaire
tiens ça c'est marrant ça
manque de confiance en soi n'empêche pas
d'être volontaire
c'est un signe d'eau ça je pense
d'ailleurs c'est un signe d'eau
j'en ai un vraiment qui me vient
spontanément mais si c'est ça je vais
commencer à croire à ce que je fais
c'est tu es en train de penser à cancer
oui
mais moi ça m'agace ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est le combien 1 2 3 4 c'est ça quatre
alors sur l'horloge ça fait 1 2 3 4 dire
que la carte associée au cancer c'est
celle-ci tu avais choisi quelqu'un je
déconne de pas choisi
ton signe et du coup ça nous fait
aboutir à la quatrième carte puisque le
cancer est 4 à la dame de trèfle là où
ça commence à me piquer un peu même moi
c'est parce que du coup la carte qui est
dans l'enveloppe c'est également la dame
de trèfle
je suis rationnelle j'ai une explication
à ça il y a que des trèfle
alors après s'il y a que des dames de
trèfle ça explique pas qu'elles aient le
même dos par contre là ça pique un peu
surtout que depuis le départ il y a pas
de dame de trèfle dans le jeu il y a
même pas trop d'autres cartes parce que
moi j'ai mis que ma carte préférée sauf
la dame de trèfle mais à la base c'est
que les détroits de cœur en fait tout le
jeu depuis le départ c'est que des
droits de cœur il y avait qu'une seule
dame de trèfle et comme par hasard
Corinne t'a choisi ça Corinne je te
prendrai en consultation
[Applaudissements]
et c'est la carte de mon grand-père mais
tu viens de péter la suite du texte
non on regarde comme ça sur
tu vois ça montre aussi ce que c'est un
spectacle qui te fait chier à faire une
mise en scène un peu originale et bien
et comme c'est un team et qu'on peut
tous se parler et que tu as bien fait je
te rassure un mec était c'est la garde
de ton grand-père
c'était l'acide du texte quoi moi je
vais le garder parce que je ferai toutes
mes consultations comme ça maintenant
non mais ça veut dire comment tu suis le
spectacle ça me fait plaisir tu sais
qu'en plus ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai rien fait avec des cartes à jouer
parce que ça fait trop magicien tu vois
par rapport à ce que je fais moi sur
scène mais ici pour moi c'était un peu
obligé que j'en fasse je vous présente
vite fait le lieu qui nous accueille
avant de passer à la suite on est au
double fond et le double fond c'est un
lieu qui a décré par Dominique du Vivier
c'est le plus vieux dédié à la magie en
France c'est les 35 ans aujourd'hui au
moment du tournage d'ailleurs et c'est
probablement le plus vieux dédié à la
magie du monde alors on dit probablement
parce qu'on sait pas trop et c'est
associé d'ailleurs à une boutique de
magie qui est elle avec certitude la
plus vieille boutique de magie du monde
et ils ont eu la gentillesse de nous
accueillir aujourd'hui ils ont plein de
spectacles je vous recommande de venir
les voir c'est des grands noms de la
magie qui viennent jouer ici c'était
très grand nom sauf qu'à chaque fois
c'est devant 30 personnes donc c'est
ultra intime voilà donc à eux merci de
nous avoir accueilli nous
merci
très bien sûr un lien vers le double
fond dans la description et encore avant
le dernier tour là ça a été construite
tout ce que vous avez vu là en 24 heures
quand j'ai plus de temps pour construire
c'est encore mieux
par exemple comme mon spectacle
archétype
que je jouerai à la Salle Pleyel le 22
novembre 2023 qui l'a déjà vu le
spectacle ici oh trop cool ben revenez
le voir il y a un nouveau numéro
le 22 novembre c'est mon anniversaire et
du coup je suis une version spéciale
petit spoil je serai pas le seul
mentaliste sur scène il y aura des
surprises des invités un nouveau numéro
une nouvelle mise en scène etc et c'est
à la salle Pleyel je vous mets un lien
dans la description et je vous mets un
lien aussi pour vous inscrire si vous
voulez connaître les dates de la
prochaine tournée vous qui nous regardez
j'annoncerai la prochaine tournée le 30
août mais le 28 août jean-berra un mail
à tous ceux qui sont inscrits pour avoir
les les meilleures places d'apport voilà
vous viendrez
merci Jojo
la dernière étape du coup pour moi c'est
que si tout a fonctionné ça veut dire
que on baigne tous dans un moment précis
c'est comme ça que je vois des choses je
pense que que les données de l'univers
existaient dans l'univers avant même le
Big Bang c'est une croyance comme une
autre tu vois mais je veux parler au
tout début des nombres irrationnels
transcendants qui contiennent tous les
chiffres et toutes les séquences
possibles c'est-à-dire que dans √2 ou
dans pi par exemple il y a un endroit où
il y a 16 millions de zéro d'affilés
numéro de téléphone suivi de ton numéro
de sécu suivi de ta date de naissance
suivi de tout quoi tu vois c'est à dire
que si je transformais par exemple Harry
Potter en suite numérique genre la
lettre A je la remplace par 1 la lettre
B je la remplace par deux etc et je
retranscris tout le livre comme ça en
nombre et en chiffres il y a un endroit
dans pi il y a Harry Potter c'est pas
une hypothèse c'est une certitude il y a
un truc qui s'appelle la tour de Babel
qui génère comme ça des milliards et
décimales j'ai écrit des phrases
précises au bureau il y avait Fanny tu
te souviens ou pas en disant je
m'appelle Fabien et là je suis en train
d'écrire sérieusement je le cherche dans
pi en le codant en chiffre et je le
retrouve et je te jure ça fait bizarre
quand même
c'est très chelou ça veut dire qu'il y a
aussi un endroit qui existe dans pi ou
Harry Potter existe entièrement mais
c'est Voldemort qui a gagné
il y a un autre endroit où Harry Potter
existe aussi mais c'est Sangoku son
meilleur ami puisque tout existe tu vois
c'est tu as vu l'infini comment ça fait
flipper donc je me dis puisqu'on est
tous connectés là dessus on pourrait
faire un dernier test généralisé pour
vérifier la connexion qui a entre vous
et moi et la connexion qui a entre vous
et moi c'est l'abonnement je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure vérifiez des fois vous
croyez être abonné vous n'êtes pas
abonné à leur abonnez-vous
faites-le vraiment
vous avez votre téléphone portable avec
vous ouais sortez-le et mettez-le en
fonction calculatrice s'il vous plaît
je vais sortir aussi mon moi j'ai une
calculatrice digitte analogique plutôt
pas digital je vais me faire un écran
voilà je vais faire des touches aussi
excusez moi c'est long à télécharger
pour moi
vous avez sûrement une touche
équivalente à la touche AC pour bien
mettre à zéro vous appuyez plusieurs
fois dessus tu vois moi ça marche là ça
a bien mis à zéro il y a un décret et je
vous demander de rentrer dedans des
données très personnelles comme vous
êtes rapproché les uns des autres je
vous demanderai d'essayer de pas être
tenté de regarder ce que fait le voisin
ou la voisine que tout ça ça existe pour
l'instant que pour vous vous allez taper
un nombre à 4 chiffres qui va être le
suivant vous allez taper votre année de
naissance en quatre chiffres année de
naissance en quatre chiffres ça c'est
quelque chose de très très personnel
évidemment et ensuite vous appuyez tiens
je vais pas dessiner je vais la faire la
touche plus donc vous appuyez sur plus
c'est fait pour tout le monde je pense
ouais donc sauf hasard de la naissance
vous avez tous une année de naissance
différente on va affiner comme ça les
différences entre vous vous allez
maintenant penser à une année qui a été
importante pour vous dans votre vie et
vous allez taper cette année en quatre
chiffres également donc ça va les
additionner
moi par exemple l'année la qui m'a
vraiment marqué c'était la Coupe du
Monde de 98 donc j'ai tapé 1998
1990 et vous appuyez sur la touche plus
donc là on a quand même affiné il se
peut que dans la salle il y a deux
personnes qui ont le même résultat mais
ça devient statistiquement un petit peu
plus rare puisque là on parlait d'année
où les autres n'étaient pas présents on
va prendre aussi une valeur aléatoire là
valeur aléatoire voilà vous avez tous la
valeur aléatoire vous la rentrée vous
appuyez sur la touche plus c'est bon
c'est fait ok cette valeur aléatoire
elle n'existe là que là que maintenant
que aujourd'hui tu vois ce que je veux
dire
ça qui est intéressant
vous allez appuyer sur plus
ça me fait chier à combien d'étapes je
vais faire encore
vous allez taper maintenant l'âge que
vous avez eu ou que vous allez avoir
cette année en 2023 moi par exemple je
suis de fin novembre du coup du 22
novembre c'est le pléielle tu connais
donc je vais taper 41 parce que j'aurai
41 ans cette année mais si vous avez eu
votre anniversaire vous tapez votre âge
là maintenant donc là je dis cette année
vous appuyez ensuite s'il vous plaît sur
la touche plus
c'est fait
on va peut-être faire une dernière étape
la toute dernière j'ai envie de finir
par un truc oublié le nombre d'années
écoulé depuis votre événement important
en gros si votre année importante
c'était 2000 bah vous tapez 23 si vous
votre année importante comme moi c'était
98 je vais taper 25 ok le nombre
d'années écoulé entre votre année
importante et 2023 prenez le temps de
réfléchir pour bien compter dans votre
tête et des voûtes vos doigts si vous le
souhaitez
vous pouvez faire ça moi ça doit donner
ça j'ai fait le compte quand même pour
moi tu peux voir toi le tien c'est juste
pour voir oui voilà
attends c'est incroyable parce que il a
4026 et moi aussi
appuyez sur égal pour voir 4000 ah oui
4626 vous aussi ben on est connecté les
gars alors on peut tout poser applaudir
4626 c'est où
ça ça veut dire qu'on était donc tous
connectés est-ce qu'il y a une seule
personne qui avait pas 4626 oui ok c'est
pas bon signe pour toi ça
je vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir
participé à One Shot girl merci beaucoup
c'est une chose est sûre
c'est qu'apparemment on est tous là
maintenant à partir d'aujourd'hui
connecter les uns aux autres on l'a été
un jour et j'espère bien qu'on le sera
pour toujours à très bientôt Ciao
[Applaudissements]
si vous l'avez pas fait vraiment ce qui
est intéressant maintenant c'est de
regarder le document avec toutes les
coulisses de la création du coup comme
ça vous allez voir ce qui s'est passé
comme prévu ce que j'ai modifié et
cetera et limite de regarder ensuite le
spectacle en ayant bizarre quoi que moi
je ferai plutôt docu spectacle docu mais
si vous avez commencé par le spectacle
ça marche aussi le lien est dans la
description pour ça si vous voulez voir
du mentalisme sur scène dans la vraie
vie avec le vrai spectacle de demander
elle est assez Excalibur c'est
maintenant que je le vois là qui a fait
ça c'est toi le dimanche on en parle
après c'est satisfaisant
je vous disais si vous voulez voir le
vrai spectacle sur scène vivre du
mentalisme ou levez la main d'ailleurs
pour monter sur scène mon spectacle
archétype va être à Paris le 22 novembre
2023 c'est pour mon anniversaire il
reste plus que 20% des places dans la
salle vous voyez le plan là à l'écran je
m'y tôt pas voilà les sièges qui restent
si vous voulez venir ça va être très
très cool parce que c'est une nouvelle
version d'archétype une nouvelle mise en
scène nouveau numéro etc etc et si vous
voulez voir le spectacle en tournée ça
sera aussi cette version là je vais
annoncer toutes les dates de tournée au
1er septembre toutes les villes qu'on
n'a pas faites on va défaire il y a
certaines qu'on a déjà fait qu'on va
refaire avec cette nouvelle version ça
c'est le premier septembre ce sera pour
tout le monde mais quelques jours avant
je vais envoyer la newsletter à ceux qui
sont inscrits avec leur numéro de
département pour leur donner accès en
premier pour qu'il choisisse les places
qui veulent dans les villes qui veulent
etc donc si vous voulez être informé
votre mail me sert qu'à ça je vous mets
un lien dans la description vous avez
juste à vous inscrire et à me donner
votre numéro de département et vous
recevrez un mail entre le 27 et le 28
août pour être sûr d'avoir les meilleurs
places c'est quand même pas si mal je
trouve voilà merci d'avoir regardé One
Shot 2 je voudrais évidemment faire un
gros merci toute l'équipe que ce soit
l'équipe spectacle ou l'équipe
audiovisuelle oui toi merci à moi parce
que c'est pas le c'est pas le plus
simple à faire et un grand merci aussi à
Gabriel Werlen c'est la personne avec
qui j'étais en visio dans le docu qui
m'a expliqué tout le procédé qu'il avait
trouvé imaginé pour pour une technique
qui s'appelle héritage et qui m'a donné
l'autorisation de m'en servir pour One
Shot 2 donc voilà merci beaucoup à lui
merci la vie merci à vos mamans d'avoir
pris soin de vous pour que vous
regardiez un jour mes vidéos à très
bientôt
[Musique]